this month in Philadelphia a
first-of-its-kind law went into effect
mandating that all businesses accept
physical dollar bills or coins in
exchange for goods and services
overall the percentage of cash payments
in the US has been dropping from 33% to
26% in just the past four years that's
prompted some businesses to go entirely
cashless but not everyone is buying in
brook silva-braga is here with more
Brooke good morning good morning guys
this move away from cash comes as
digital options like Apple pay and
PayPal have become more popular Amazon
has open stores that automatically
charge you for what you pull off the
shelves the cashless craze has also been
embraced by lots of upscale fast casual
restaurants catering to city office
workers for some these so-called
frictionless transactions offer speed
and convenience but many Americans are
still reliant on cash and they have the
support of an unlikely champion there's
a good chance you know a guy like
William Greenlee if you like the good
old Philly cheesesteak chaddy
salt-of-the-earth type the guy who
slides up to a register it's like one
lemon and still pays cash thank you and
so when Greenlee found a coffee shop
right downstairs from his Philadelphia
office that wouldn't take cash well that
just rubbed him the wrong way everybody
comes into Center City business
employment entertainment whatever but
not everyone could buy a coffee exactly
and not everyone could go in there and
buy a basic product the thing is really
is a Philadelphia City Councilman and so
he proposed and passed legislation
making Philadelphia the first city in
the country to force retailers to take
cash
unfortunately Philadelphia has been
called of poorest big city in America
which means you know there are people
who do not have credit telling people
who do not have the ability to have
credit that you can't buy a basic
product is not treating people fairly
poor people have a lot of serious
problems
why focus on the right to buy a $14
salad or five-dollar coffee when there
are other more pressing issues why
I guess I would say we can do more than
one thing at a time in an era of vast
income inequality and skepticism over
fast-moving tec-9 William Greenlee had
stumbled upon a strangely galvanizing
issue San Francisco and New Jersey
followed with similar bills legislators
from New York City in Washington DC have
called him for advice I think it hit a
nerve with people to be perfectly honest
with you
what's the nerve you're you're telling
me that I can't use the currency the
United States of America just last year
cashless seemed cool the owners of dos
mouros taqueria told CBS News they
rarely had to turn away customers
wanting to use cash I know China's
basically they're already there two
forks another fast casual spot touted
the increased efficiency of going
cashless with every cash transaction the
payment process was slowing down
significantly what a difference a year
has made at least one cashless company
sweet green is now accepting cash again
and the others don't seem excited to
talk about it we reached out to every
cashless company we could find and none
of them would speak to us on the record
in the past they've argued cash is a
headache to manage it slows down the
line and leaves stores vulnerable to
theft you see this trend continuing we
won't be using cash will be using laugh
and laugh economics professor Ken Rogoff
was willing to talk about the problems
with cash he's the author of the curse
of cash and argues among other things
hard money fuels crime human trafficking
drug smuggling big time
tax evasion it would be better he thinks
if we were more like Sweden where cash
is nearly been phased out and the US
will get there to Rogoff says in another
five or ten years there's no question
that cash you know is in its last era
electronic payments are being favored by
consumers forget the businesses we're on
the Harvard campus here if you talk to
my undergraduates you know they'll say
well you know what do we need cash for
unless we're buying marijuana
that's funny if and when cash fades away
Rogoff has an idea for helping the 20
million Americans who live in unbanked
households meaning they don't have any
bank or credit accounts it would not be
that expensive to provide free basic
capita cards to people and a number of
other countries have done this
India's done it I mean if India can
afford to do it we can afford to do it
but the march from paper money to the
digital future has taken a notable
detour in Philadelphia as the city
considered its cashless ban Amazon
warned officials that the legislation
would discourage them from opening a
cashless Amazon ghost store in Philly
but in the end it was not William
Greenlee who caved I understand Amazon
go on my say yeah yeah they do take cash
you know they they did not at first and
then they they have decided to do it
that might have something to do with you
well maybe not just me but I think the
fact that this anti cashless thing yeah
it's spreading around I think it did
have something I don't apologize for
doing this I think it's the right thing
to do greenly told us that after the
bill passed sweet green reached out to
him and said they had never intended to
give the impression that they were
excluding certain customers when you
still have 20 million unbanked Americans
you have to figure out some way forward
right without just saying we don't take
any cash and this isn't just about
salads obviously as the economy is
moving in this direction more and more
products will be harder to buy with cash
and that's what people were worried
about go ahead I was just gonna say
maybe everyone should have a credit card
of some kind issued by our Jolly Green
Giant you know I mean let's be real here
that's what it's gonna take if we're
moving in that direction yeah that's
what row golf the professor wants to see
happen some countries have done it not
easy to implement it's also you look at
the homeless on the streets now is so
few people carrying cash yes that issue
and if you still is one for them but you
wonder if you could create some type of
credit system for everyone could that
change some of that I know that's a
completely different issue but it is
something out there without the cash
again thank you